sea lions have been hurt in the wild are
helping veterans deal with
post-traumatic stress disorder
it's part of a unique program in
Southern California up to 20 percent of
veterans returning from recent tours
overseas have PTSD according to the
Department of Veterans Affairs Carter
Evans now shows us how the veterans and
marine animals are helping each other
feeding time can create a frenzy all of
these animals were rescued along Orange
County's coastline and brought here to
the Pacific Marine Mammal Center some
sea lions are sick some injured right up
here krinkle came to us with a broken
flipper Kolby Holly Baja a former Marine
leads the sea lions for servicemembers
course he's been diagnosed with PTSD and
that's helped him empathize with wounded
animals like this sea lion named Sion
Zion was very badly entangled and pinned
down against the buoy it's all a lot of
meetings I on the ioan thought he was
doing just fine he was gonna figure it
all out on his own right and it's not
until someone helps you that you realize
how badly you needed the help veterans
Lisa Stein in Erica Thea to La Vie
discovered the program while searching
for help for PTSD a lot of time when you
get out especially if you have PTSD
you're lost you're nervous and crowd you
have nightmares you can't talk to
anybody that's a lot like these animals
they have no voice like the military not
all the work here is glamorous but these
vets agree caring for the animals has a
calming effect it clears your mind
because all you're doing is sinking or
looking at their eyes and their whiskers
and flippers focusing on their behavior
and kind of how almost calming it was to
see them and it's just like okay weird
animal is non-judgmental the Marine
Mammal Center has rescued more than 180
animals this year in some require
surgery in attitude veteran Naomi
Project watched as a critically ill seal
was too fit seeing an animal fighting
for life triggered memories everybody
was scared I know for me it was my
emotions I couldn't control my
oceans at all and I felt like I was
really weak but each found strength
working alongside other veterans and
bonds formed just like the sea lions it
was a life-changing what is it about
putting veterans together it seems to
create something special they can feel
like a team again and they can feel like
they're doing something positive they
can look in their eyes and they can
understand that the animal I struggle to
and the animal is a peach it's not
broken because it made it helped when
the animals recover the vets are invited
to witness their return home and like
battle buddies in the military they're
released with a friend to help them find
their way it was very emotional because
they were on to another chapter and it
was felt like that was like what I was
dealing with on to another chapter it's
just like you learned in the military
sometimes you're gonna have to crawl
along under the barbed wire and that's
just what you have to do until you find
yourself getting that stride of service
back it's a new mission for these
veterans helping sea life to heal and
maybe he lead their own invisible scars
along the way for CBS this morning
Carter Evans Laguna Beach California
what a great crowd great story it's so
true as I said sometimes you don't even
know you need to know until somebody
actually knows how much you need it in
the first place to have that and the
documentary back-to-back you realize how
big an issue this is yes PTSD